welcome back to cbs this morning we're
focusing on president trump's case of
the coronavirus
wall street opened lower this morning
after the news of his positive test
investors also reacted to this morning's
september jobs report showing
the unemployment rate dropping below
eight percent but
the slower pace of jobs growth this was
the last monthly jobs report before the
election
cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger joins us
jill good morning to you what do you
think we should expect from the markets
today well i think it's a bumpy ride
the markets are certainly trading at
better levels than they were just a few
hours ago but it's a long day before
the end of trading now that said i think
that that
jobs report very important here although
we did get 661
000 jobs we now have seen four
consecutive months where job growth is
actually
tapering lower that's not a great sign
investors are also quite concerned that
without any further stimulus
we are going to have a problem
recovering all of these jobs
we still have almost 11 million
fewer jobs than we had before the
pandemic
you add to this the uncertainty of the
president's
testing positive and you have some
investors worried
that they just better go to the
sidelines individual investors
you don't have to do that you know
anthony we never try to time the markets
sure is jill schlesinger thanks so much
jill